yeah welcome to this video this is some
a new 15 minute game it's a dual
commentary game some both players some
will do comentarii also my friend
Brandon here will do a video on his
channel we play a game of 15 minutes um
and five second increment of a move so
that we will have the chance to play it
out at the end and it's not dumb super
tough time trouble um also I'm the
ratings are a bit weird looking as I'm I
should be the clear favorite in the game
but I never played the same this time
here I was played the 15-minute pool um
okay let's decide on a movie i'll play
em an irregular looking move knight c6
CM it's quite interesting and i hope to
UM can maybe irritate am a bit um young
normal moves on of course t54 the Queens
gambit or be 60 k a three-year seems to
to know em to know this new me now
transpose to get to the two nights tango
go g6 now and black will play g6 Bishop
g7 85 going for sort of phone Kings
Indian setup but yet has some funny
nuances we will maybe see some of these
later White has made this move a 3 which
is not done especially useful sometimes
of course that can prepare before but in
some circumstances a three sm even known
even a slight problem okay Bishop g7 you
know it I know it looks a bit weird
young this e 66 but um I will play if I
for kings in yen but I won't play it
again instantly but only with some
preparation we will see him castles and
now it probably castles as well it
doesn't need to I can play out the moves
but it will turn look like pretty pretty
normal and now on yes the MDI DM groupie
8 the idea is to play 'if I've and then
on d5 goal night deform and this is even
working on Bishop e3 sober should be 3e
5d 594 and black has a comfortable
equality the only a slight issue is some
that it's a bit of a dolt position so
Bishop e3 e5 d5 night deform this is the
idea instead of this night is heaven
maneuver and the Kingston year web okay
and this is of course some possible
controlling g-form probably he didn't
like it should be three energy from
possible okay but now let's go e5 after
d5 I will definitely go to deform
yeah be transposed from this some tango
tango line into really pure Kings Indian
setup so of course no position that you
would get in the pure Kings Indian
because well a three and h3 are somewhat
strange moves in this opening and I lost
11 move of course with the 65 yeah okay
let's um let's get to deform the thing
as if you look at this night e7 now in
comparison the night only seven simply
doesn't control any square I mean it's
just a very bad bad piece on e 7 in the
pure Kings Indian we have wild where
black goes to to attack with f5 there
for the night later goes to g6 but for
the moment it's not a great piece on
only seven ok so on what what do I do
now it's not like he's threatening on
default because um I have this nightly
form so Knight d4 ed for Bishop the
phone that you form and it's it's fine
for black the question is should i just
take on e 2 or f3 and continue on should
I play c5 which would be interesting if
yeah there was in term this office or
capture ok I'm if takes on c6 yeah if I
recapture with the beak on Wendy fall is
still not hanging but I don't know
probably I should just them
go ahead and grab grab chance I know the
the bishop looks like the the bad bishop
but still I'd rather capture this piece
and then the night on a three because of
the night at three Bishop f3a don't can
I cannot play Knight h5 and that five
which I'm yeah which I wanted to play so
this some speeds up the the kingside
ideas of course here the rook is not so
great on yet I would prefer to have it
back on fh considering the damn going to
play at five but yeah that's um you
cannot have it all night e 1 this is
interesting I'm not so sure what what
what this night is doing and it maybe
he's going to be three but ok and also
f5 of course f-5e fgf the night is
saying and Bishop f5 there's g-form I'm
not sure that this really am is a
problem for black mmm no in fact I can
go nite a form on g4 so I could play
f-5e takes Bishop Jake's not sure that
it's good but I could I could do it but
I'd like Queen edge for actually why not
create strong this prepares f5 put the
idea eat xfg jxf and maybe I'm really
menacing night f4 Bishop h3 stuff like
that the night looks at the Queen look
some quite interesting here but night b5
and I should have thought about this
that be
if it's Maybelline idea now mmhmm yeah
this was silly I should have paid more
attention to this okay it's not the end
of the world if he plays not be five now
i can i can drop back to e7 and ok can
take a seven but this is not the most
important pawn really well this looks
like a very weakening move ok let's um
do some some calculation Nigerian Queen
f2 with some bit of a self pin and I
don't I don't really have a move then Oh
f5 they are maybe f5f5f5 that even night
f4 is of course i'm also on to be
considered he probably plays Queen f2
dumb the app Queen Queen back to g5 or
something it should be ok for black but
then you had them many many interesting
moves also just ff5 all tonight f4 I
mean this is really am why can I have a
big big choice don't think i can i can
already a sacrifice on edge to edge for
this sir atrium this is this is too
early I need some some more pieces also
f5 is probably a good move simple simple
now f5 Queen f2 and then the Queen
probably needs to a retreat yeah this is
one of the cases where you have from
lots of good looking moves and it's
difficult to to decide actually what I'd
like to do is also somehow get in Bishop
to h6 exchange those those bishops so
when he weakened his dark squares
enormously with age three and f3 and the
from to get to exchange the bishops this
would be M really held at the moment
it's it's not not such a problem this
bishops needs to get exchanged and yeah
he said it's got this night night b5
thing going if I would play f5 to f4
just in general terms this Bishop um
isn't so great I'd like to exchange it
really
maybe maybe what about Queenie 7 let's
just think about this Queenie 7 this
would cover c7 saw that night b5 is
simply no go doesn't really work it
would threaten 93 because there's not
this help in any more and also I may be
preparing but should f 62 g 5 or f 62
were to h4 maybe this is a good idea
yeah also i'll play that has spent so
much time now he also needs to react to
into night or g3 even light a for Bishop
age 60 as an idea now okay simply
ignores this hmm yeah okay I'll take the
exchange on cam and so it's still an
exchange
yeah the position is still fairly closed
so it's not an immediate disaster to
give up the exchange but it's it's not
not like em white as having any
compensation for it he will get to play
c5 and have sub summer quit I play but
okay it's the Kings Indian normally a
black get slaughtered on the queenside
anyway and here it looks like a white so
need some some time to get something
concrete
yeah this is some thank a good idea to
control g5 so that Bishop f6 g5 isn't so
easily possible but okay let's go let's
grab the exchange and yeah should I play
a five at some yeah probably yes hard to
imagine that I cannot do without this
move for long
yeah what what what this is plan you
will play c5 obviously and maybe not be
five but this isn't really a threatening
much the question is some should I
exchange on e4 to open the position and
exchange some material like taking and
Bishop f5 exchange in one of the nights
after F take you will take with the
night of course to get the square you
form and then I can exchange some stuff
but should be a five taking only form
it's um probably probably a quite decent
way to continue but at the end you will
always have this night only form which
will be has yeah the corresponding p.m.
for the rook for the exchange that I'm
ahead the alternative is to play F form
and go ahead g5 h5 with some some Kings
item attack yeah I actually believe this
this should be it should be much better
I mean the other the other way is simply
solid but especially due to this move
being possible Bishop f6 I like this
much more I can play Bishop f 62 h for
all you must make some some very
unnatural move like we knew one which
would clog up the the rook and simply
it's certainly very passive to play this
way so I'm in this way I can play Bishop
h4 get rid of the bed Bishop and then go
with g5 h5 g4 and try to open up the G
and H files for the rook and its really
some time until here white is got some
we had Freddy IM he decided to prevent
this this Bishop move the the only
problem is some that now this is all or
clogged up he hasn't work and no way to
get some some activity going
yeah this is the only one takes and
might be five I than just play a six and
he can just retreat so it's it's just
nothing and I'm threatening g4 now
already this will get them a dangerous
attack very very quickly yeah there's no
way to prevent them to form yeah let's
play it simple you know just you mean we
must just retreat now we kick a plane at
a seven but this is so yeah sort of a
night with no return just go Bishop d7
and then G form
yeah okay I could also spend more time
preparing but for example I'm Bishop d7
would be would have been a good
alternative covering a four or so is the
only idea is now not a four to be 6m
after provoking and v6 weakness to
donate a form quite resigned yeah this
was some early with them it's pretty
much pretty much over the sir attackers
decisive I think 11 major problem here
was some of you return for a couple of
moves that here it begins some um here
here it begins where it gets gets
already a bit tricky and I think very
problematic is to move f3 which just
weakens all kinds of squares and um like
know as a big choice of good good setups
um yeah it just asked if you should
should do another game maybe we should
you should do that this was rather
rather quick one someone I'll go here
and issue a rematch
let's see if it's got the time to UM to
do that yeah after this some legs
possibilities are great you can also
think about instantly going to g3 game
of started so we had a new game rather
than back again I got black I thought I
would get white but ok no no big deal
hmm yeah well we've seen this position
now before right 30 seconds from once
not exactly a good way to spend your
time ok so I'm ok let's let's start
another six then I've got lots of
options open and what else could I
player basically had the Kings in your
last time ok let's let's try something
completely different
I'm doing form from the old Indian for a
change
yeah discount the the old Indian I'm I
think because of this was played
sometimes before the Kings Indian really
turned into a popular opening which
means I'm it was in the late 40s right
after the second world war with players
like Bronstein and Karis picking up the
Kings Indian with g6 and before there
have been some players who played this
kind of setup and this became to UM be
known as the old Indian I think new
salvage for example he played this kind
of setup ok an immediate d5 this is
interesting so on what should black do
now we have an early commitment in the
center by white which also gives me the
square c-54 my night in fact 95 looks
like a rather decent move alternative
some surely something like Bishop e7 or
a 5 hmm I'm not so sure if I should play
Knight c5 so early it would have the
advantage of attacking um II form so
that maybe he needs to play a 3 not
necessarily but this is the most them ok
didn't do it the most natural way to
defend your form came so I'm here
probably before some threat if not now
then in the very near future so I now
spent the move to secure the night on c5
oh this is this is very early playing a
move like this I was not threatening a
for so it's so different if white would
have played III before then then I would
have threatened 84 but III is really
only it's not not necessary move at the
moment so the question is now I should I
am play Bishop e7 or should I go with
g6g 6 of course always would have the
advantage of preparing also f5 later but
Bishop e7 has got the point that maybe I
can move the knight on f6 and play
Bishop g5 to exchange this somewhat bad
bishop and this is something which is
which is very nice to achieve okay he
played nine to f3 is there some way to
get rid of from the bishop interesting
maybe I should I could I could try that
it's interesting the ideas i on i assume
he's playing yeah he's playing this move
and then i would take and play in 97 and
Bishop to g5 let's do that and say it's
interesting to get rid of from this is
bad bishop this is probably not the
absolute best way to play but it said
it's interesting I wonder why is not so
recapturing instantly
GTX f3 after night h5 is just a disaster
so pretty much I very clear advantage
for black instantly she takes f night h5
is terrible we should be 03 is so just a
mandatory move don't maybe that's some
connection problem I don't know
interesting you really took some time on
this move so nigh to d7 and Bishop g5
right this was the idea at least times
there's some other place where I could
go yeah after castles 98 but her castle
he might play HD 398 h4 at least this is
what I would would consider this only is
working this pursuit g5 stuff because
right now yes absolutely no way to
prevent it otherwise this taking on a
three would be entirely pointless I
really net need to get get this get
displayed yeah and after this I have a
position with two nights against night
and bishop and this bishop on f3 SL of
course not the greatest piece but then
it's not a big deal it's not like I'm
this Bishop has some big core cause for
concern and this is simply because why
does still enjoys a very considerable
space advantage it's this position after
the the bishop exchange gives black a
fair chance but it's not better white
them with the space advantageous always
ideas to go a 3 B 4 C 5 this kind of
stuff and open up more space even for
his bishop very often this bishop
so can go to g4 and simply exchange
itself like 1d seven maybe Bishop g4 now
kids probably not good to allow the
doubled pawns on III but in general to
reroute this Bishop to the h3 to see a
diagonal it's a good idea for white for
example I'm something like taking on g5
Quincy five and then and the long run g3
h4 and getting them Bishop to h3 so
Queen move yeah not much choice I need
to need to take this and yeah what now
the night on this happiness of course am
NOT not very well placed question is
some should i reroute it instantly f 69
f 6 would have them advantage of
preventing a budget reform what else
with them maybe time maybe i can can
consider h5 h5 hmm
gaining some space and also preventing
should reform also they're the Queen
moves Queen f6 for example but I need to
be cautious about night b5 this might
take c7 and then I don't really know
what what my responses yeah I also i
could try to play em something like
Queen m62 f form also an idea yeah if i
put the knight on f6 now those ids are
pretty much out of the game activating
the the Queen quickly what else could I
do I could also just castle of course
another idea is to play c6 Queen B 6
something like this but I should really
cancel first for this ok let's cancel
fine that some it's a difficult
difficult thing ok and I was slightly
worried that white might go go go inside
and then play G 3h Freud f4 or something
like this but it doesn't look like him
that this was on his agenda at all
yeah no one with this Knight f6 okay
let's play this I cannot spend all day
on now on this so what would be am a
good way to continue what I would like
to do but this is really some sort of
ideal scenario is to play c6 exchange on
d5 if wide recaptures with the C porn I
would like to play be five before this
would be like the dream am exchanging
see pawns and b5 before so that the
knight on c3 would need to move and then
he's really tired to defending the e4
pawn and have a 4f two great nights on
f6 and c5 that both attacking form and
c6 taking and b5 would also um yeah
prevent all kinds of play from white
okay yeah he's aiming for a three and
before himself so maybe I should yeah
there should go for this I mean c6 is a
good move anyway he cannot really take
because this some removes the d5 pawn
from controlling he six so that I have
instantly night e six to deform he
cannot take yeah the Circe wants to be
expected the question is if I take on d5
now maybe he's taking with the e porn
and this could be could be a slight
problem and one thing is I can play a
four of course a 4 B 4 night b3 and to
deform okay come on let's take first and
think about this afterwards
yeah a for now on is this is this really
nonsense the thing is if he goes before
let's say I do a nothing move yeah and
he goes before it takes before entering
it takes before ok one book a one-night
be three with the tempo and naturally
for I'm great in this position so I'm
it's not really a big threat this be
formal the question is some what what
should I play now if this isn't a threat
Queen to clearing the Queen somewhere
probably 27 I mean the nights are okay
27 wat kappa b 5 i could also play Queen
B 6 it's not them that's not entirely
terrible
I'd like to connect rooks this is why
I'm thinking about a queen move Queen B
6 also will prevent before of course and
to term put control be fire and gam not
sure yeah I need to move turn up turn
invest even more time
you
yeah it looks fairly solid I mean I'm
always um I can always count on the
somewhat weak bishop on f3 it's not
doing a match but one way to activate it
should be true to be five something like
this and this shows that this Bishop
isn't terribly bad okay but first of all
he cannot go before we already saw that
before I take on before a beer okay one
rucca one Queen B form you winning a
pawn you can go before takes rook before
but then I can take on before a beer
okay one and probably black exactly
better with two rooks thank you for the
Queen so before it's really no move I
think why should consider something like
Bishop e2 or maybe if you want to play a
very very direct way can move the night
and try to play before but before isn't
so terrible anyway I mean before it
takes takes 97 besides the fact that I'm
can I can win the spawn as mentioned but
can always just drop back to the 7 and
cover the Queen the only weakness that
have is d6 anthem this is some not um
not a huge issue I hope okay this is
interesting that is an interesting move
good move maybe it protects me three it
wasn't hanging but it protects it and
protects a false or so he's sort of
maybe preparing before in the in the
long run this could be I could be a good
idea yeah but how do i improve him maybe
rook c8 he is still not threatening
before and rook c8 look so looks good
operating on the C file
and yeah I think he will probably play a
slow move like Bishop c2 rg3 something
like this h3 some slow move then i can
think of King f8 king of a dozen move
that I like because I'm in this scenario
where the Queen's I exchanged like after
Knight to d7 queen bee 696 and he goes
tonight be five then I could just play
king e seven and protect this weakness
so king of a dozen move that term I
could consider if he goes for some some
slow move
yeah I no no I'mI'm Bishop c2 has the
problem with 97 and these pieces are
really bad on the C file this is a
problem for YTM he's got no food her
wood on the C file maybe you should
should consider yeah this is actually a
good idea maybe you should play
something like Lucy one rook c1 and then
look a to be one and then preparing
before not sure that it's such a great
thing anyway to get beforehand but look
to see one looks looks decent anyway
okay and yeah I'm not not so sure what
this is doing
hmm see threatening before yeah well
takes and queen and drug takes um I
don't think this can be a big problem
really and it takes 97 hmm okay I'll
play this viet preparation move 497
yeah yeah before so the move that he is
preparing all the time I think but it's
still on still not a terribly a
threatening well this is surprising I
thought them he would be a bit a bit
weak on the CFR now if I play Knight to
d7 of course roque to was a good
hammering booth okay but I i I'd do this
the CM cannot just stay in this
situation all day and I don't mind the
Queen exchange I've got the rukon the
sea Farland he's got no foothold on this
on this file if he plays Queen d3m I
have this ideas of what Queen d2 I have
this is a queen d for idea maybe this
isn't great yeah he can maybe take and
plane I'd be five now that I think of it
but Queenie to I could could consider a
Quincy five this locks are looks looks
to some would we add a white like you
needs to move the night to some some
really wrong place d one on or a form
remove the Queen understand ok quindi
for probably night be 5 p.m. ok like
Quincy five probably night yeah night to
somewhere strange you too maybe each
yeah but maybe I should just maybe why
not just double on the C file it's the
only open file you should put your rock
solid on it it's an ancient rule but
some cases the rules still apply di
Rossi eight now threatening probably
needs to move the Knights now I'm in
anticipation of the smooth like my term
don't know 91 maybe lad you want to III
something like this could be it could be
an idea
ok one of those strange squares hmm yeah
where do we go now yeah both be five i
have a6 i have a similar d4 looks looks
weird yeah probably here with a simple
idea of pushing be five
yeah just look see it coming maybe you
should consider Bishop d3 covering the
b5 square
yeah it's some slightly uncomfortable
position for white the pieces don't
really am coordinate well hmm amazing a
Jeff that why does times law for this
kind of move okay let's play rook c8
first cannot be bad taking this file one
ideas also um sometimes to just go 95
exchange exchange the e4 night I know it
looks like a very solid piece but in
general exchanging a pair of lights to
have to pure good night against on
somewhat questionable bishop scenario
isn't so bad question is Sam is this
really the the best solution i doubt
that it looks some very uncoordinated
for why to this position but still on 95
is not not a bad move it can also go
route see one but it doesn't really am
bring so much benefit at the moment i
try to exchange that
yeah and now I'm possible next move
would be roots III rooks III pinning on
the third rank and then queen deform
it's like invasion on the dark squares
oh ok let's let's play this simple but
but good move 24 so yeah Queen obviously
it would be very nice on deform yeah
should i do this instantly on there are
other ideas let's let's try this night
h5 getting this idea into the position
could be a quite annoying for white
there's also this Queen only seven which
can be really tricky let's say plays g3
and then I could simply take on g3
because of this pin on the a7 g1
diagonal so I'm this Queen on a seven is
so quite a quite a dangerous piece of
white and he's also running a low on
time if you would play before by the way
am I can consider more than one reply
probably just taking even a 3 is also
hanging
mm-hmm it tries to relieve some pressure
with exchanging yard zone valid ID of
course a turn let's let's try this night
air form now g3 this kind of stuff it's
so very annoying with little time on the
clock simply because you cannot play g3
here just take it I just I just take it
yes sir as mentioned yeah the queen is
very well on a seven it's very good post
I hope I'm not overlooking some stupid
double attack or something but I don't
think so alright so now let's let's
check what what's best here
maybe there is some direct direct way to
to win Quincy form look sir looks quite
good term Quincy form or maybe it's got
Queen h6 something like this yeah
probably em all kinds of moves win okay
let's let's go to deform the Sun cannot
be bad really threatening on d3m I mean
rook takes t2 we have group texts to
Bishop takes Queen DeeDee to threaten
term and term yeah all kinds of stuff in
94 you can give this check but I just go
to g8 and it didn't didn't them do am
white any good
yeah i can i can play 94 even right and
maybe he's got this check then lady for
Bishop before words Queenie to assess
all them
yeah I'm okay let's check Roxy to Roxy
to Roxy to Roxy to Quincy to camp at
nighttime 985 to our form it's pretty
much curtains so not not position that
you would like us wide okay come on keep
it simple so only that's only one point
to learn in any game of chess if you see
a winning position in a continuation you
could you should simply play it often
and not think about any great great
beauty prize winner or something
sometimes you spend so much time on
trying to figure out a nice way to win
that you actually is spoil the win okay
this is just the yeah the odds down
light on f4 cannot get any better
yeah h3 also hangs okay so um how to how
to win this now he's probably
threatening like a can give this check
and them get to get to the spawn maybe
them go here and a Quincy five check osf
ag7 o and queen on c5 it's just simple
covers all pawns and a text a three and
if he exchanges the st. game is some
pretty easy win all right okay if it
takes you six now I'm not sure if I
should ready okay about this this looks
look symptomatic here and now i'm
covering covering this nice lady six and
A five go into before yeah could be but
at the moment the queen is covering
everything nicely that would play Queen
before he exchanges slightly worried
okay but he never gets to he never gets
to the B porn I was slightly worried
that maybe you get his King to see for
something had to take this form but he
will never be able to there's simply no
way d3 is covered by the night and C 3 a
3 also
light forfeits on time I didn't manager
move here okay but the position is
really very bad I would have liked to
show the the technical part but ok
overstep the time what the easiest for
for black is to try to organize the long
run some attack on the king with the
Queen and night combination but i just
wanted to tidy up on the queenside
before i do anything on the King side so
on this is ok the exchange is also yeah
the winning end game from for black all
right yeah I hope you enjoyed those two
games it was a pretty long session ii of
almost one hour and didn't really um
awesome everything really plan for for
this longer video yeah i hope you
enjoyed it make sure you also check out
Brandon's version of the game i post a
link in the description to make it
easier to to find the corresponding
video yeah thanks for watching and I'll
be back soon